as if we needed a real doctor to tell us that
the protests against Corona virus social distancing
were a bad idea.
We now are hearing from top infectious disease
Dr. Anthony Foushee, who is saying in clear
terms these protests will backfire.
These protests will slow down the economic
recovery.
Now, the answer.
The response is, of course, obviously, but
I'm sure that hearing it from a doctor will
make the protesters take heed and understand
the importance.
Right?
Wrong.
Protesters over the weekend were actually
caught on video chanting Fire Foushee.
I played that video for you yesterday.
Let's look at yesterday's Good Morning America
on ABC.
Here is Dr. Foushee saying it himself.
And finally, sir, we're seeing these protests
crop up all across the country right now,
including the protests in Texas and other
places where they're saying fire Anthony Foushee
Foushee is wrong.
They're resisting the stay at home orders
from governors.
What's your message back to those protesters?
Yeah, I mean, I think the message is that
clearly this is something that is hurting
from the standpoint of economics and the standpoint
of things that have nothing to do with the
virus.
But unless we get the virus under control,
the real recovery economically is not going
to happen.
So what do you do if you jump the gun and
go into a situation where you have a big speech,
spike, you're gonna set yourself back.
So as painful as it is to go by the careful
guidelines of gradually phasing into a reopening,
it's going to backfire.
That's the problem.
Unless we get the virus under control, none
of this matters by reopening now.
You will get some short term economic benefit.
There will be nominally businesses that go
back online and start earning some revenue
and start paying some taxes.
Okay.
But over the long term, the economics are
going to be worse from reopening the way that
these protesters want us to reopen right now.
It's genuinely and truly sad that this is
simply another political disagreement.
It's just another political football to throw
back and forth.
The science is clear.
The medical world is clear.
Any premature opening is going to lead to
a spike in cases.
And in the long run, it will cost us dearly.
Maybe we get three to four weeks of so-called
economic productivity.
But it's like the experiments about I don't
remember who did these, but there's these
experiments with 5 year olds where you go
in and you put a cookie in front of them and
you say, I'm gonna leave the room if you wait
10 minutes.
You'll get a second cookie.
And some of the little kids are more patient
and they wait and they get that second cookie.
And a lot of people can't and they just eat
the cookie anyway.
Tons of people are stuck on the idea of opening
now without realizing that if we do this difficult
thing, we can hopefully open permanently a
little further down the road instead of opening
now and then having to close again and then
opening and closing endlessly until we have
a treatment and a vaccine.
So, of course, Dr. Anthony Foushee is.
Correct.
But understand that once again, it's foushee
in science.
On one side and Trump and these sycophants
on the other side.
And we're supposed to believe everything is
just fine and there is no obvious conflict
there.
Except that Trump recognizes things are so
bad that he has to suspend immigration altogether
to the United States.
Fouche, he says, do not open and do not protest.
While Donald Trump said over the weekend,
liberate Minnesota, liberate Michigan, liberate
Virginia and save your great Second Amendment,
it is under siege.
And remember that Trump also said over the
weekend the protesters are the ones being
treated roughly and that they are protesting
in a responsible manner.
Well, I think we do have a sobering guidance,
but I think some things are too tough.
And if you look at some of the states you
just mentioned that it's too tough, not only
relative to this, but what they've done in
Virginia with respect to the Second Amendment
is just a horrible thing.
They did a horrible thing.
The governor and he's a governor under a cloud
to start off with.
So when you see what he said about the Second
Amendment, when you see what other states
have done.
No, I think I feel very comfortable to be
clear, when you talk about these states, Michigan,
Minnesota, Virginia, do you think that they
should lift their stay at home owners?
Can you talk with elements of what they've
done is too much and it's just too much?
You know the elements because I've already
said sure.
Are you concerned, though, that people coming
out in protest are going to spread to other
people there congregating in ways that health
experts have said they should not?
You know, these are people expressing their
views.
I see where they are.
I see the way they're working.
They seem to be very responsible people to
me.
But it's you know, they've been treated a
little bit rough.
This is a direct contradiction.
I know who I'd trust on it.
But there are trumpets who want Dr. Foushee
fired for trying to keep America safe.
You need only look at history to know what
the right path is.
Look at studies of the economic impact of
the 1918 flu in the United States.
We have found that the cities that implemented
the early measures and kept them suffered
no adverse economic effects over the medium
term.
The short term was bad, no doubt.
But the states that opened earlier, the places
that opened earlier in the 1918 flu pandemic
did better in the short term, but much worse
in the medium to long term.
You've got to grin and bear it in the short
term.
You will do better in the long term.
We can't miss the forest for the trees here,
and sadly, the president of the United States
is actually encouraging these protesters to
do that.
Dr. Foushee is clear.
The science is clear.
I don't know that we're going to actually
end up on the right side of this one.
We'll have continued coverage of this and
other stories from today on The David Pakman
Show Instagram page.
If you were on Instagram and I am, go to David
Pakman show.
That is our Instagram account.
While you're there, follow me at David Pakman.
My urban garden soil has arrived.
I am planting.
I will be documenting all of it on my Instagram